світ 31-й рік Незалежності Україна
зустрічає визвольної війною за власну
соборність самостійність та
територіальної цілісність я захищаю
незалежність тому що Україна Мій дім я
захищаю незалежність тому що зараз це
Найбільша цінність саме вона дає нашому
народу можливість жити а нашим дітям
спокійними майбутнє і заради
незалежності Ми зараз всі служимо і
працюємо я захищаю незалежність нашої
держави Щоб мої сини й доньки мали
можливість вільно обирати своє майбутнє
я захищаю незалежність Бо Україна - це
мій дім моя Батьківщина це Мамина
колискова та батькові поради це місце де
виріс я і мої рідні я борюся за
незалежність України для того щоб моя
нація і в подальшому існувала у цьому
світі вільна жива та і самостійно робили
своє майбутнє Та добре чому я захищаю
незалежність України на тому що майже за
моєю спиною знаходиться школа де
навчається моя Онука а поряд з нею в
дитячому майданчик на якому бавляться
діти мого побратима я захищаю
незалежність тому що бути вільним
європейським народом
Це моя мрія і мрія мільйонів українців я
захищаю незалежність нашої держави тому
що за мною стоїть наша Україна наші люди
наша земля наша честь і наша можливість
жити так як ми вважаємо за потрібне чому
я пішов захищати свою Україну тому що я
не хочу бути рабом і не хочу щоб мої
діти були рабами між жінки і не всі
українці щоб вони не були рабами і в
мене є мій девіз Вот він на шеврони
Написано якщо не ряд То хто я захищаю
рідну землю бо я тут народився тут
поховані мої рідні тут росте має донька
і мої близькі я захищаю свій рід і буду
захищати до повної Перемоги І на
оновленій землі брага не буде супостата
а буде син і буде мати і будуть люди на
землі Так ми обов'язково і беззаперечно
переможемо бо ті нації які героїчно
боряться перемагають і мають успішне
майбутнє цього року мирне небо над
Україною дається нам Дорогою ціною ми
втрачаємо цвіт нації захисників України
але незважаючи ні на що ми переможемо
Україна переможемо бо наш бій за свободу
і щасливе майбутнє без рабства
українці
вільний народ Чого рабан ніколи не
зрозуміти чому ми переможемо та тому що
ми світло а світло завжди промовляємо
урок Україна переможе Бо ми на своїй
Богом дані землі за нами правда і весь
світ Чому ми повинні перемогти у нас є
класні Круті люди які нам допомагають
наближають нашу перемогу ми обов'язково
переможемо Тому що правда за нами і нас
підтримує увесь світ ми їх переможемо
все буде рок-н-рол шановні українці з
Днем Незалежності Слава Україні
[музика]